a digital employee can help you get work
done faster
it helps you with repetitive mundane
tasks so you can focus on the bigger
picture
having a digital employee is like having
your own sidekick an executive assistant
or a new teammate that is trained to do
a specific set of tasks
imagine having your own intelligent
digital worker that just for you and
your team
that can do things for you like generate
a monthly report or onboard a new
teammate or onboard a new vendor
how much time would you save how much
more productive would you be
but how would it work
and how is it different from a
conventional software robot
I'm Leslie Chao product manager at IBM
Automation and today we're going to open
up the hood and peek in
but before we dive in if you like this
video or want to see more like it please
like And subscribe
there are three key characteristics that
make a digital employee effective at
helping you and your team do work
and that's
identity
context and planning let's start with
identity
a digital employee has a name and a
profile in your work directory it has ID
and login credentials and that's really
important for two key reasons for the
first
having a name and profile also means it
has a drop profile and specific things
that it does in the company
that allows folks in your team to be
able to know to go to the digital
employee for specific asks just like
with your human colleagues you know to
go to Bob for HR things and Sally for
finance things
the second reason is security
with access and ID comes Access Control
this allows you to secure and protect
your business systems and provide your
digital employee access to specific
Business Systems and specific
applications and data so that you can
protect those
next let's go to context
context and memory gives your digital
employee context of what you do as a
business as well as a conversation that
you and your colleagues are having with
it
that's really important for two reasons
one it makes the conversation flow much
more naturally
that way it remembers when you when
you're having the conversations or asks
that you're giving in so that way you're
not spending more time asking and typing
and explaining yourself then just doing
it yourself
so you can say something like generated
financial report and then say send it it
the digital employee has context and
memory of the conversation that's had
with you so it knows that it is the
financial report and to send it by email
second reason is it understands your
asks better so that you can say things
whether it's create a report or generate
a report or generate a statement you
know that those mean the same thing to
you and the employee also knows those
would mean the same thing it means
generate the financial report
last but not least is planning
planning is what makes a digital
employee special
the digital employee has AI that allows
it to generate a plan or plans to
accomplish a specific goal so when you
ask it to do something like generate a
monthly financial report
it looks into its repository skills that
you gave it and come up with a plan or
plans to accomplish that goal
for example the digital employee can
look into The Ledger database directly
it can generally report in Salesforce or
maybe it will look into a Dropbox folder
to see if someone else has already put
it there
it will present this these options to
you and give you a recommended amended
options and let you decide how you would
want to generate a monthly financial
report
so there you have it digital employees
have identity context and plan
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below